hola cómo te va en el vídeo pasado hablé
sobre algunas de las fuerzas internas
más débiles y bueno no podemos decir
estructuras de elementos por supuesto la
más débil era la fuerza de dispersión de
london te acuerdas en este vídeo
comenzaré con la estructura más fuerte y
esta es la red covalente la red
covalente y bueno si tienes un cristal
de red covalente o un cristal covalente
y ojo es importante recalcar lo que es
un cristal recuerda que un cristal es
cuando tienes un sólido dejaron ponerlo
aquí cristal cristal cuando tienes un
sólido donde las moléculas que componen
ese sólido están en un patrón bueno
relativamente consistente esto es lo que
se le conoce como un cristal y por
cierto se compara muchas veces con lo
que es un sólido amorfo
ok pero en el sonido amorfo tenemos una
especie de masco lanza y hay diferentes
concentraciones de diferentes cosas de
diferentes iones de diferentes moléculas
y de diferentes partes de un sólido así
que el cristal simplemente es una
estructura muy regular el hielo por
ejemplo es un cristal porque bueno
porque cuando logras que el agua esté a
una temperatura lo suficientemente baja
entonces los enlaces de hidrógeno forman
un cristal una estructura regular como
las que hemos hablado en un montón de
veces así que la más fuerte de todas
estas estructuras es la red covalente y
el ejemplo principal de todo esto es el
carbono cuando forma un diamante cuando
tenemos un carbono y dejen de utilizar
este color aun cuando tenemos un carbono
bueno pues este carbono tiene 4
electrones de valencia por lo que
siempre quiere 4 más así que cuando el
cargo no comparte consigo mismo pues es
muy feliz y entonces
esto hace que se forme una red déjame
ponerle más o menos así de carbonos
con enlaces covalentes forma cuatro
enlaces para cuatro carbonos más y
después cada uno de estos carbonos puede
formar enlaces con otros cuatro más
aquí tenemos uno aquí sería otro aquí
sería otro y bueno por aquí vamos a
tener otro más y este también por aquí
otro y por aquí otro y por aquí otro y
así todos los demás aquí tendríamos
otros y aquí tendríamos otros y después
se forma la estructura de un diamante y
la razón de por qué esta es una
estructura tan fuerte es porque debes de
ver el diamante entero como una molécula
porque todos tienen enlaces covalentes
todos estos son enlaces covalentes y
están compartiendo realmente electrones
y en realidad como están compartiendo
sus electrones este es el enlace más
fuerte que existe como comparten los
electrones este es el enlace más fuerte
de todos los enlaces moleculares así que
puedes imaginar que si el sólido entero
está hecho de esta red de carbonos vas
un punto de ebullición de la sustancia
extremadamente alto y es por eso que el
diamante es tan fuerte y es tan difícil
es hervirlo muy bien ahora si pensamos
en los siguientes dos y déjame para eso
subir un poco la pantalla porque si
pensamos ahora en los siguientes dos
enlaces que quiero que ver uno de ellos
por cierto es el am enlace de cristales
iónicos antes gran ponerlos y cristales
crisis tales iónicos iónicos y yo
y el otro déjame ponerlo con un color
distinto se me ocurre este es el enlace
de cristales cristales metálicos
cristales metálicos
y de hecho estos dos tipos de enlaces
nos van a decir qué tan sólido es un
sólido o dicho de otra manera la próxima
versión más sólida de un sólido y
depende sobre qué caso estamos hablando
el cristal iónico más común es el
cloruro de sodio vamos a decir que si tú
veamos algo de sodio déjame ponerlo con
este color si yo tuviera algo de sodio
por aquí y algo de cloro bueno y si
nosotros nos fijamos justo por acá abajo
en nuestra tablita que tengo justo por
acá que es nuestra tabla periódica
fíjate bien en esta tabla periódica por
aquí tengo mi déjame ponerlo con este
color por aquí tengo al sodio este de
aquí que por cierto tiene un electrón
extra que está muriendo por perder
mientras que por otra parte por aquí
tengo al cloro y el cloro tiene siete
electrones de valencia por lo cual le
hace falta uno y muere por tener un
electrón más así que esencialmente el
sodio va a donar su electrón el sodio se
vuelve positivo
y el cloro se vuelve negativo para que
recuerdes de qué estamos hablando
ok en este caso lo que va a pasar es que
el cloro se va a volver negativo
mientras que el sodio se va a volver
positivo porque va a donar su electrón y
esto hace que quieran estar muy cerca
los unos de los otros correcto entonces
tienes unión de sodio positivo y unión
de cloro negativo y la estructura de
esto se va a ver más o menos así
entonces si ponemos el sodio
de este color vamos a tener primero por
aquí un montón de sodio tenemos más o
menos así estos van a ser sodio y por lo
tanto tienen carga positiva ok
justo como así de esta manera y por a
camps se les van a pegar un montón de
cloro es que vamos a ponerlo con este
color si yo tengo por aquí cloro a bueno
pues esto se pegan aquí tengo un montón
de ellos que se van a pegar con claro
con carga negativa una carga negativa
que hace que se forme este tipo de
estructuras y bueno tal vez ésta no sea
exactamente la forma que son en realidad
pero creo que ya entendiste la idea de
que uno
como es positivo y el otro átomo es
negativo así que ellos realmente quien
está cerca los unos de los otros para
estar bastante felices entonces esto es
un enlace bastante fuerte y por lo tanto
tiene un punto de ebullición muy alto
aunque en realidad este tipo de
estructura es muy frágil
así que si tomas un poco de sal de mesa
completamente seca y no disuelta en agua
y si tienes un gran bloque de eso y
luego el pas con un martillo bueno pues
verás que tendrás una gran porción
dispersa de eso solo que va a caer de
acuerdo y esto es porque básicamente lo
estás cortando a lo largo de estas
líneas muy rápido y eso es lo
interesante siempre que hagas algo a
macro escala como cortar algún tipo de
esas substancias realmente lo que estás
haciendo es rompiendo estos enlaces
atómicos así que la fuerza de los
enlaces atómicos realmente te dice lo
fuerte que algo es ahora que está si
hablamos de los cristales metálicos a
los metales les gusta deshacerse de sus
electrones o bueno tal vez no deshacerse
de ellos les gusta compartir
así que si por ejemplo tocamos el caso
del hierro y mediante que por aquí voy a
dibujar algunos átomos de hierro estos
de aquí y déjame poner que estamos
hablando del hierro
ok este también el hierro este también
el hierro y bueno también tenemos un
montón de electrones en el caso del
hierro es que tenemos un montón de
átomos de hierro y esos electrones se
les permite vagar libremente así que
este es un electrón este es otro
electrón y bueno por aquí tenemos un
montón de electrones por aquí vagando
entre ellos y script este mar de
electrones y bueno recuerda que los
electrones tienen carga negativa cada
uno de éstos tienen carga negativa y
curiosamente justo por esto es que los
metales son buenos conductores de la
electricidad y por supuesto ya que los
átomos de hierro han permitido que esos
electrones paguen todos llegan a ser
ligeramente positivos este átomos
ligeramente positivo un ligeramente
positivo este también este también
así que están embebidos en una malla o
mejor me gusta pensarlo como un mar de
electrones entonces los cristales
metálicos dependiendo de en qué caso
mires a veces son más fuertes que los
cristales iónicos y a veces no
obviamente podríamos enumerar una gran
cantidad de metales muy duros pero
también podemos enumerar una gran
cantidad de metales muy blandos por
ejemplo en oro
si tienes 24 quilates de oro puro y
tomas un martillo y golpeas el oro se
apoyarán cierto así que esto no es tan
frágil con un cristal y único de hecho
con frecuencia se moldeará a lo que
quieres hacer con él es un poco más
suave incluso sociales de los metales
muy duros tienden a no ser tan frágiles
por el mar de electrones porque esto te
da un poquito más cuando te mueves
alrededor del metal de hecho a veces
justo esto es lo que da la capacidad del
metal de doblarse o flexionar sé en
realidad es justo esto es lo que tiene
el poder de desviar la fuerza a la que
se le aplica
por lo que esta fuerza y ya he tocado
esto en varias veces esto también entra
en el punto de ebullición así que debido
a estos enlaces que son bastante fuertes
tenemos un punto de ebullición más alto
y es que si solo tomas al cristal de sal
e intenta servirlo tendrás que añadir
mucho calor al sistema así que eso tiene
un punto de ebullición mucho más alto
que cosas que solo tienen la fuerza de
van der vaart aun con por ejemplo si
recordamos lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado a ammán recuerda que los gases
nobles
es decir estos que tenemos justo aquí
tienen un punto de ebullición más bajo o
por ejemplo tiene un punto de ebullición
más alto de lo que lo tendría por
ejemplo es lo duro de hidrógeno el
fluoruro de hidrógeno si recuerdas en el
último vídeo sólo tenía fuerzas dipolo
dipolo pero lo que es interesante sobre
esto es que estos electrones tienen un
punto de ebullición muy alto a menos que
estén disueltos en el agua es decir que
si nosotros tomamos a la dejamos subir
un poco en la pantalla
un poco de esta sal que tenemos aquí
justo aquí ya está sal la disolvemos en
agua bueno pues los cristales iónicos
pueden ser disueltos y entonces el punto
de ebullición baja y de hecho cuando se
lleven el agua pasa lo siguiente déjame
subir un poco esta pantalla porque vamos
a formar los famosos a enlaces iónicos
bipolares y déjame ponerlo así y únicos
irónicos ok bipolares di hola
o bueno también se le conoce como los
enlaces polares iónicos así que déjame
aquí ponerle polares también para que
los recuerdes polares y es que si
recuerdas nosotros habíamos visto que el
agua se formaba más o menos así tenemos
una molécula aunque tiene un extremo
negativo tenemos justo aquí al oxígeno y
por acá está un hidrógeno por acá tengo
otro hidrógeno y aquí se formaba una
carga negativa recuerdas aquí tenemos
una carga negativa porque el oxígeno
está acaparando los electrones mientras
que en los extremos del hidrógeno
tenemos una carga parcial positiva carga
parcial positiva en este lado y bueno
esto es porque están cediendo un
electrón al oxígeno así que cuando pones
estos iones de cloruro de sodio va a
pasar lo siguiente como el sodio está
ligeramente positivo entonces am aquí
vamos a tener al sodio cerca cerca de
esta parte negativa ok vamos a ponerle
aquí que su carga es positiva mientras
que por otro lado tengo aquí
loros ok los cloro se van a acercar a
esta parte aquí tengo el cloro con una
carga negativa ok el cloro que está
cerca de los hidrógenos así que como se
disuelven en el agua todavía quieren ser
atraídos el uno al otro pero también se
sienten atraídos a los diferentes lados
del agua así que esto les permite
disolverse e ir con el flujo del agua
bueno esto a pesar de que estos se
sienten atraídos y bueno lo irónico de
esto es que cuando nosotros nos fijamos
en el caso en el que disolvemos un
cristal joanicó en el agua como un
cristal único no es un buen conductor de
electricidad y eso recuerda dónde está
acá arriba si nosotros nos fijamos en
esta parte de aquí date cuenta que no
hay nada que se mueva en este estado por
lo tanto un cristal iónico no es un buen
conductor de electricidad pero
curiosamente si nosotros nos fijamos acá
arriba va a pasar algo súper padre
tenemos estas partículas cargadas que se
pueden mover y bueno eso es porque el
agua se puede mover y de repente cuando
pones sal o cloruro de sodio en el agua
éstas se convierten
de todos modos al menos quiere
explicarte todas estas diferentes formas
de la materia y claro ahora deberías
tener una idea cuando veas algo antes de
bajar un poco cuando veas algo de esta
tabla periódica y veas los enlaces que
están creando es decir qué tipo de
enlace inter molecular se está dando y
por lo tanto qué tan alto debería de ser
su punto de ebullición si tenemos un
punto de ebullición alto o un punto de
ebullición bajo dependiendo si es fuerte
o no la manera general de ver esto es
qué tan fuerte son los enlaces
inter moleculares obviamente si toda la
estructura es una sola molécula va a ser
muy pero muy pero muy fuerte por ejemplo
en este caso que tenemos aquí en esta
red covalente de carbono pero de otro
modo si estamos hablando de neón a mí
déjame subir un poco la pantalla para
que hablemos del neón si nosotros
hablamos del neón y tenemos por ejemplo
por aquí un montón de neón
aquí tenemos algunos átomos de neón
déjenme ponerlo así bueno pues tú puedes
recordar que está en estado gaseoso y
por lo tanto tenemos una fuerza de
dispersión de london
como tenemos una fuerza de dispersión de
london tenemos unos enlaces muy débiles
así que un gas está casi en su estado
más natural recuerda si consigues mucho
frío podría ser capaz de conseguir que
esto se volviera líquido y después todo
lo demás que ya hemos visto en fin de
cualquier forma espero que todo esto lo
encuentres bastante útil